George Hill to the others along with
Clarkson arriving hood games fines tops
tops a little finish well you better
pull fast and Tristan Thompson a spark
off the bench
Nathan backs up four to shoot paid him
on the drive falling away puts it up
puts it in those shot clock expires
would you shut the damn door store on
loop back in Boston where he was an
assistant coach Riley who'd count it and
the foul
games against Morris falling away you
could hit in that shot to prep these
playoffs eight points and five rebounds
but here's what you talk about coach
unnecessary switch Oh Kevin Love on a
perfect pass from LeBron James seen good
shots this is outstanding individual and
team defense Brown for free tucks it in
[Applause]
throws here
Celtics guards good rebounding guards
Brown gets in the paint puts it up shot
bounces up and in rebounds he's 8 of 10
from the field
George Hill the drive and finished I
like that though the smart floats it out
to Tatum Tatum the Morris Morris good
open look it's a free Marcus Morris his
second three-pointer he's got 14 victims
regain control once again Tatum
shake-and-bake free partner 525 point
blowout
[Applause]
lebron james quickly exits just 15
points on 5 of 16 from the field